- Now I'm going to divide you guys up,
we put the lights on because I want to try
and make sure you feel
responsible for your suggestion,
if the lights are off,
it's just some gross guy
in the corner just going,
"Waxing your asshole."
And no one wants that.
(audience laughing)
So, there's a gentleman
at the back laughing
at that heartily like,
"That is exactly what I was going to do."
I see you bro.
(audience laughing)
So, let's come to the back section first.
If you are in that kind
of booth-y section,
what would you like, there's
some hands up over there.
What would you like a rap about?
- [Audience] Cars!
- Oh, okay, well let's be more specific,
cars are a very general topic,
a specific type of car or
something to do with cars,
like making sure you check
your oil or something.
- Dodge Dart.
- A Dodge Dart?
Let me just check, that's
a tiny shit car, right?
(audience laughing)
- Yes.
- It'd be really funny if the person
who said they were English is like,
"Oh, he now insulted
my awful car as well."
Okay, so the Dodge Dart,
which is a tiny, bad car,
why does that come to mind in particular?
- I don't know.
- That's okay,
that's a valid reason.
- DeLorean.
- What?
- Oh, DeLorean, well okay,
Dodge Dart versus DeLorean.
Thank you, you made the suggestion better.
Let's come to you guys, this is
kind of a sparsely attended area.
Why is everyone packed over
there and no one over here?
I mean you guys look
really unhappy about it.
What do you guys want to
rap about on this side?
- Klingons.
- Klingons?
And you've got a hand up
over there, what'd you want?
- A space-traveling
malpracticing urologist.
(audience laughing)
- A space-traveling
malpracticing urologist,
that is better than a Klingon I'm afraid.
I know we could combine
them, but to be honest,
I don't want to corrupt what
is an exceptional suggestion
that you've clearly been
thinking about for quite a while.
Okay, a space-traveling
malpracticing urologist.
Are you familiar with Cool Keith
and his character Dr. Octagon?
- I am.
- Yeah, really,
or are you just saying that
because I've said that?
- He's a gynecologist.
- Yeah, he is,
so that Cool Keith is a rapper
who has a character of
a space gynecologist,
so I was wondering if
that was similar to that.
- I say urology because she's in urology.
- You said urology because she's in,
you've been outed as a
urologist I'm afraid,
at least he didn't say you were
space-traveling or malpracticing,
(audience laughing)
that's okay.
So, Dodge Dart versus DeLorean,
a space-traveling malpracticing urologist.
Let's come to kind of
the middle of the room,
you guys are a big group,
let's come up with something great.
- White people.
- White people (laughs)?
(audience laughs)
That's a great suggestion,
let's expand that thing,
let's focus on a specific
thing white people do,
like, I don't know, kissing
their dogs or something.
(audience laughing)
Someone else can help out on this as well,
it doesn't all have to
come from the same person.
- Drinking.
- Astro cheating scandal.
- Wait wait, so you
said drinking something,
but then you said the
college cheating scandal,
is that right?
- Astro, baseball!
- Oh, the Astro cheating scandal,
wait, was that just white people?
(audience laughing)
I mean I imagine the coach and
the owner of the franchise
were white, okay.
White people and how they love to cheat,
especially in baseball.
(audience laughing)
You guys are making these
suggestions really hard.
Dodge Dart versus DeLorean,
white people and how they love to cheat,
the space-traveling,
malpracticing urologist.
Guys over here, what do you
want to hear a rap about?
- Airport security.
- Sex toys.
- Airport security and sex toys,
getting a sex toy
through airport security,
I like it.
(audience cheering)
That was a very cool moment, it was like,
"Yeah, we did it! When
women work together,
we can be and do anything!".
(audience laughter)
Okay, and let's get one final suggestion,
and this should be really good,
because so far, these have
been at such a high bar,
so I don't want you to let us down,
this one can come from anywhere.
- Sasquatch!
- You said anime,
you said Sasquatch, and what did you say?
- Sequins.
- Sequins, okay, cool.
I'm gonna say Sasquatch with sequins,
I like that, that sounds more fun.
I've done a rap about
Bigfoot specifically,
recently, so I kind of want to make
it more difficult like that, okay cool.
Sasquatch with sequins (laughs),
getting a sex toy
through airport security,
a Dodge Dart versus a DeLorean,
a malpracticing,
space-traveling urologist,
and the Houston Astro's cheating scandal,
but focusing on white people.
(audience laughing)
Okay,
guys, usually I make
big promises about this,
I'm like, "This is gonna be
the best thing you've ever seen."
And I am doubting myself right now,
but don't worry, it's gonna be good,
it's gonna be better than you're expecting
a privately-educated middle
class white British boy to be.
That's what I promise, let's
drop that beat good sir,
let's have some fun with this,
I am very excited.
(audience clapping)
(energetic hip hop music)
♪ Chase on the beat ♪
♪ Yeah, kick it let's go steal signs ♪
♪ Look at all the singles on the Astros ♪
♪ In Houston, near Texas,
they want to select ♪
♪ They're trying to figure
out what pitch comes next ♪
♪ You can lower it down,
staying close to the ground ♪
♪ I'm the catcher, making
sure the pitcher is found ♪
♪ A little signal, but
luckily I don't see ♪
♪ An iPad with the camera behind me ♪
♪ Send it to the coach
and he loves to boast ♪
♪ "I'm a rich guy, yeah, and
the opposition's toast" ♪
♪ Even though they're winning, ♪
♪ They didn't get kicked out, MLB, ♪
♪ Baseball, sort this shit out ♪
♪ Why, 'cause they're going and bleating ♪
♪ And we know white people,
they're loving the cheating ♪
♪ They say, "We got privilege
but it's still tough man." ♪
♪ So they cheat like Felicity Huffman ♪
♪ Trying to get kids into colleges, ♪
♪ You should educate your
kids where the knowledge is ♪
♪ You don't need to pay
people to fake exams, ♪
♪ If you're into baseball
in the off-season ♪
♪ Just learn how to predict the pitch, ♪
♪ Don't be a damn
cheating son of a bitch ♪
♪ Who's white, yeah, I was mistaken ♪
♪ I thought all the
Astros were Caucasian ♪
♪ Only a small portion, nah, ♪
♪ Let me try and raise
you in the Porsche car ♪
♪ But I'm always beating
you in the quarter mile, ♪
♪ 'Cause you drive a Dodge
Dart, it's a car for a child ♪
♪ 'Bout this big, made by Dodge, ♪
♪ When it comes to mechanics,
it's a real hodge-podge ♪
♪ The engine's shit and
the horsepower's weak ♪
♪ It's got no grip, you could
drive it in your sleep, ♪
♪ And if you crashed it wouldn't matter, ♪
♪ Your bones wouldn't
shatter, let me talk about ♪
♪ A scientist and mad hatter,
from Back to the Future, ♪
♪ I'm not boring again,
talking about the ♪
♪ three movies with the DeLorean. ♪
♪ The first one, a real wild guy, so fly ♪
♪ Saying, "Sup Marty McFly,
my name's Christopher, ♪
♪ You can call me Doc Brown, ♪
♪ my DeLorean is the talk of the town." ♪
♪ Only 'bout 30 were ever sold, ♪
♪ If you've got it with
the flux-capacitor, ♪
♪ That's like gold,
all the nerds buy it, ♪
♪ They get annoyed, they
try and keep it secret ♪
♪ In the garage like a sex toy ♪
♪ In your baggage when you carry-on, ♪
♪ If it's double-ended,
go into the TSA line ♪
♪ And know your friends
hid, weed, and drugs ♪
♪ And other stuff, but
you have got a big ♪
♪ Purple dildo that you'll wanna stuff ♪
♪ Inside somewhere, in the cavity, ♪
♪ TSA agents saying,
"Understand the gravity, ♪
♪ You can't steal this."
Really trying to try it, ♪
♪ You got to disinfect it,
remove all Coronavirus ♪
♪ Samples, I know it's amply sized, ♪
♪ I try and fit it down
there, between my thighs ♪
♪ And all the people
on the X-ray machine ♪
♪ Raise their eyebrows when they say, ♪
♪ "Wow, this one is green-y." ♪
♪ Can't tell the color from the UV rays ♪
♪ I take this dildo it goes on for days ♪
♪ And if you put it inside,
it's a heck of a risk, ♪
♪ You might get infected,
need a urologist ♪
♪ But this one, he's not in you face, ♪
♪ He's up there when he's
going through space, ♪
♪ And when you get a vibrator
that the buzz so strong, ♪
♪ Buzz Aldrin and Neil
Armstrong could meet this guy, ♪
♪ 'Cause they're up in the universe, ♪
♪ A urologist, he says, "Get naked." ♪
♪ First, pull your pants
down, get on the couch ♪
♪ Bend over, Chris, get
your posture, don't slouch ♪
♪ He inserts a little
finger into my urethra, ♪
♪ I wish there was
lubrication making it easier ♪
♪ But sadly, he goes in
dry, it's horrible, ♪
♪ It really makes me wanna cry, ♪
♪ My eyes, ah, I feel
like I'm self-destruct, ♪
♪ Like a star trek vehicle
when he instructs me ♪
♪ To get right in there,
what was the last word ♪
♪ That we need to take care, ♪
What was the last one, oh yeah?
♪ Kind of boring but I still share, ♪
♪ I'm in the forest, looking
for a grip-toed creature ♪
♪ If he wore sequins it would be easier, ♪
♪ 'Cause he shimmers in the light, ♪
♪ So he comes out at
night, creeping up behind ♪
♪ The tourists and giving them a fright, ♪
♪ And they run away,
jump like hopscotch, ♪
♪ From the massive sequined
creature called a Sasquatch ♪
There you go.
(audience cheering)
Thank you very much for watching,
please watch more with playlists here,
subscribe here, like, comment,
all those things, shouting, bye!